more than 185 people have been killed
and some 400 injured and explosions at
churches and hotels in Sri Lanka in the
last few minutes reports have come in of
another blast close to the capital
colombo previously six explosions had
been reported in colombo as well as the
town of negombo and batik aloha and the
east of the country the earlier
explosions went off simultaneously a
church in colombo was one of the
buildings hit other targets were
five-star hotels more than 30 foreigners
are reported to be among the dead Sri
Lanka's Prime Minister has convened his
top military officials in an emergency
meeting to coordinate a response to the
blasts he denounced the attacks on
Twitter posting I strongly condemned the
cowardly attacks on our people today I
call upon all Sri Lankans during this
tragic time to remain united and strong
please avoid propagating unverified
reports and speculation the government
is taking immediate steps to contain the
situation for more details on this
developing story I'm joined now by
asanga Abiah guna secara head of the
institute of national security studies
in colombo sri lanka mr. aboah guna
secara were getting reports about
another blast in or near Colombo do you
have any information on that I guess it
was just reported a few minutes ago
thanks called the Ebola which is a just
closer to Colombo and - probably - who
have been succumb to death and we and
this is the seventh blast place today
and Paris for the victims you witnessed
one of the attacks today you were inside
one of the targeted hotels when it's
when it all happened could you tell us
about what you saw I was in the
shangri-la Hotel and the so my family
waiting to celebrate Easter breakfast
with friends Christians when the blast
went off at around 35 so and this was
actually targeting the restaurant on the
third floor where everybody was having
an impact exciting so this is where the
hospital so we we witnessed many victims
and
there were so many victims and like to
see and and there was to actually
sexually and she will absolutely through
Psalms and it was quite and we caught
the meet resistance immediately which I
thought is is right next to the Sharia
and there was assistance from glad to
hear you say what do we know about the
other sites targeted well Christian
Science in Anthony's Church is one of
the most sites where Christians come and
they come from then and and also many
slices and this is because this is
celebrating Easter and if you look at
the past attacks from Saturday this
Easter day we could Pakistan
again this actually and police actually
say that foreign intelligence agencies
warned them about plans for an attack
ten days ago could this have been
avoided but then we need to look into
that information because
[Music]
[Music]
this information in this information
mean you're trying to you're saying you
have identified extremist groups and
that extremism is on the rise in Sri
Lanka what's the reason for that you
think well if you look at it ever since
the post war there's been from the 2015
government which is a funded soon after
so there is many changes done to the new
traditions and there were many forceful
if you look at it a certain like
dimitra's ations there being certain
Muslim nations have been in every
question was to demilitarize and reduce
security and all that they don't
understand the the threat that we have
as a nation and we have been fighting
our terrorism for 30 years and using
bomb times and
so I think one should understand from
the inside that although the requests
are we really want to be utilized and
also the reduced intelligence operation
well they shouldn't make that case now
it's very clear that we should
strengthen our intelligence and because
we have to protect our people and this
is something and if you look at a few
months ago detonators were found in the
party area that is on the west coast and
then so these are actually things that
we cannot ignore and this is serious
issues that certain are really good and
so right now
so because the investigations are going
on only 7% of Sri Lanka's population are
Christian you've said of course that
this is the worst violence in the
country since the end of the civil war
ten years ago have there been other
attacks against this religious minority
in the past but there has been places
and all but not not not taking lives and
also but me government of Sri Lanka has
been promoting disharmony and
conciliation after the war there has
been great effects done on this
particular area but there are individual
cells they are linked to different
extremist groups and so the our
intelligence are actually monitoring
them and we as you can see the convinced
applause so I think we will be able to
conclude
they organized that how did to presume
sites and so we could find the
perpetrators and we will definitely find
because samantha is honest formation
with our intelligence our groups were
service boots so maybe we'll find them
and maybe the sangha but you're gonna
see Kara from Columbo thanks for your
analysis